c'est le ministère de l'Intérieur qui
réglera la facture d'honoraires que je
présenterai bien évidemment il paye tout
tout le policier a aucun moment même si
il est reconnu hier relax et même s'il
n'y a pas de
policier ne verse rien il y a dans le
11e arrondissement de Paris une
patrouille de police est appelée pour
une altercation entre un automobiliste
et une contractuel au sujet d'une amende
nous sommes également équipés d'une
caméra cachée afin de ne pas perturber
cet échange entre policiers et citoyens
c'est une histoire de scooter malgré qui
a dégénéré
selon le conducteur du 2 roues la
policière lui avait donné la permission
de se garer sur le trottoir
et puis on fait pas un couteau dans le
dos
je pouvais vous pouvez vous mettre le
problème
donc voilà l'outrage est un délit pénal
il se règle au commissariat
on se fait insulté donc limite
agressivité des faces ça nous arrive on
ne bouscule donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
bon on va porter plainte et voilà
au commissariat l'officier de police
judiciaire doit décider si l'outrage est
constitué depuis 2002 insulté ou se
rebeller contre un fonctionnaire de
police coûte plus cher jusqu'à 6 mois de
prison et 7500 euros d'amende le jeune
homme pense en avoir pour une heure il
se trompe
c'est l'heure de votre interpellation en
outrage à agent de la force publique
pour ça je m'étais dit une dépôt et puis
je suis pas assez au pire une réprimante
ou je passe au tribunal pour ça
c'est grave c'est grave d'insulter une
personne qui fait son travail de [__] et
de la menacé de mettre une droite la
prochaine fois qu'elle prenne son boulot
ce soir là faute de place en cellule il
sera finalement libéré reste que
l'altercation avec la contractuelle
aurait pu lui coûter cher
les relations seraient-elles en train de
se tendre entre policiers et citoyens
qu'est-ce qu'un outrage que risque-t-on
à contester une verbalisation enquête
sur un délit pas comme les autres
[Musique]
dans les commissariats le policier qui
porte plainte est devenu une scène de
plus en plus habituelle plus de 30000
plaintes en 2008 deux fois plus qu'il y
a 10 ans les policiers assurent qu'il
n'en relève qu'une infime partie ce
policier parisien a été insulté lors du
transfert d'imprévenu on a regardé
fixement
en disant que que j'aimais pas les
Arabes que j'étais un sale raciste de
merde
à l'intégrité physique ce sont des comme
je disais souvent des injures à
connotation sexuelle exacerbée et là
c'est l'outrage habituel au sens c'est
pas l'automobile c'était pas monsieur
tout le monde qui dérape là
arrondissement je me suis déjà fait
insulter mais c'est la première fois que
que je dépose une plainte pour un
outrage porter plainte en cas d'outrage
rien de plus facile tout se passe entre
policiers du même commissariat
un mélange des genres unique endroit
français pour certains une porte ouverte
aux abus
pour la dépénalisation du
devant le Salon de l'Agriculture ce
jour-là une poignée de citoyens en
colère demande que l'outrage ne soit
plus un délit pénal
simple automobiliste Serge a été
condamné pour outrage à agent de la
force publique
le délit d'outrage c'est tout simplement
ce qui se passe si jamais vous avez un
jour un petit souci avec la police ou la
gendarmerie et vous êtes
systématiquement accusés de rébellion
d'insultes etc et n'importe qui le
citoyen lambda peut être touché dans
n'importe quelle condition
je vous en prie certains policiers
utiliseraient-ils une loi destinée à les
protéger pour avoir toujours raison en
toute circonstance
la mésaventure de Serge s'est déroulée
en 2005 à Ezanville au nord de Paris sur
le parking de cette grande surface
ce jour-là Serge se gare en passant par
dessus le trottoir
Sabrina sa fille âgée d'une trentaine
d'années est assise à l'arrière dans la
voiture d'à côté un automobiliste pas
comme les autres individu qui était à
l'arrière du véhicule a commencé à
hurler chauffard inconscient vous auriez
pu tuer quelqu'un etc etc je suis écouté
quand c'est les bonbons quand c'est les
pieds tout ce qu'on peut imaginer dans
ce genre d'altercation et c'est à ce
moment-là qu'il a sorti sa carte de
gendarme c'était un homme en civil avec
son épouse avec son bébé
mais voilà je suis gendarme
là-dessus j'ai dit bah écoutez vous
faites ce que vous voulez j'en ai rien à
[__] les choses en reste là mais une
semaine plus tard Serge a la surprise de
recevoir une convocation à la
gendarmerie plus surprenant encore sa
fille Sabrina est elle aussi convoquée
pour avoir pris part à l'altercation
[Musique]
on me dit monsieur vous reconnaissez les
fêtes qui sont là sur un document qu'il
avait dans les mains et on m'a demandé
de le signer
donc lecture a été faite
et j'ai refusé dans un premier temps il
y a quelques reprises puisque j'étais
pas du tout d'accord avec les termes qui
étaient employés
et puis là les menaces garde à vue
emprisonnement
qu'est-ce que vous allez devenir en
garde à vue etc bon j'ai jamais vécu ce
genre de situation et
chez signé je pense que
j'ai ainsi avalisé effectivement toute
l'accusation qui venait derrière
Serge et Sabrina signent s'excuse et
ressortent libre mais deux ans plus tard
convocation au tribunal de Pontoise
Serge et juger en premier verdict 500
euros d'amende avec inscription au
casier judiciaire
aujourd'hui c'est au tour de sa fille
Sabrina d'être jugée
Sabrina a pris un avocat Maître Ursula
un ténor du barreau parisien
le gendarme lui n'est pas venu ça
hiérarchie ne l'a pas autorisé à nous
parler
j'aurais préféré qu'il soit là pour
assumer pour prendre ses responsabilités
comme moi je les prends
mauvaise nouvelle pour la défense de
Sabrina la juge et la même que celle qui
a condamné son père six mois plus tôt
2 heures plus tard le verdict est tombé
qu'il était pas en il était pas en
exercice de ses conscience donc pour
Sabrina 200 euros d'amende pour outrage
la juge n'a pas tenu compte du fait que
le gendarme n'était pas en service
vous avez
l'impression d'avoir été entendu quand
même d'avoir pu vous exprimer donnez
votre point de vue votre
Sud oui mais moi j'ai pas eu
l'impression qu'elle m'écoutait
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que le
gendarme a été écouté même s'il n'était
pas là
le problème c'est une question
Sabrina a décidé de faire appel pour
elle encore un an et demi de procédure
dans la majorité des cas pour la justice
ces paroles contre parole parole de
policiers contre parole de citoyens la
difficulté pour le citoyen qui conteste
est d'apporter la preuve qu'il n'a pas
insulté les policiers près de
Valenciennes se perdent de famille a
pris trois policiers en flagrant délit
de mensonges la preuve il nous la montre
c'est une vidéo depuis plusieurs mois
une querelle l'opposait à son voisin au
sujet de leur cour commune une banal
histoire de voiture dont les policiers
se sont mêlés crayon une connivence il
glisse se sont caméscope dans sa poche
pas d'image mais l'échange verbale est
très
clairs veulent l'interpeller mais ils
n'ont aucune raison légale de le faire
écoutez bien ils vont inventer un délit
d'outrage
nous avons du poids de flics connard de
flics l'homme est emmené au commissariat
ses enfants laissaient seuls à
l'intérieur de la maison toujours sous
le choc Marie et femme n'ont pas osé en
parler à visage découvert trois ans
après
le commandant du commissariat et j'ai
demandé une audience pour que on
m'explique ce qui s'est passé alors j'ai
expliqué que je voulais qu'on m'explique
en tant qu'épouse parce que je
comprenais pas pourquoi on avait placé
mon Marion garde à vue en tant que maman
parce que je comprenais pas bien pour
qu'on avait laissé mes enfants sans
surveillance et puis en tant que
citoyenne parce que je trouvais que
c'était fort de café de créer un outrage
et puis de laisser mon époux dans un
état lamentable psychologiquement et
puis de commettre une telle injustice et
en fait là c'est une fin de mon recevoir
et ça c'est absolument révoltant grâce à
son enregistrement l'homme a été relaxé
mais cette histoire lui a coûté 2500
euros d'avocat il détruit
toute chose là son
comment protéger les policiers dans leur
travail sans permettre ses abus à l'IGPN
la police des polices installée et Place
Beauvau ministère de l'Intérieur le
commissaire baudet assure que les
garde-fous existent
les abuses sont très faciles à détecter
je les nie pas ils existent certainement
mais pour l'autorité hiérarchique ils
sont très faciles à détecter on le voit
sur le comportement des grains de la
paix lorsque un fonctionnaire va
plusieurs fois dans l'année être au cœur
d'une polémique autour d'un outrage on
va s'intéresser à ce qui conduit ce
policière va ses difficultés là alors ça
peut être un problème de formation ça
peut être un problème d'encadrement ça
peut être un problème personnel mais ici
pas question de renoncer à ce délit la
grande majorité des policiers ne s'en
serviraient que dans les cases extrêmes
toute la difficulté tout l'enjeu il est
là c'est que celui qui est victime de
l'infraction est celui qui l'a constate
mais pour vous il y a pas de solution
comment voulez-vous est-ce qu'on doit
accepter de d'insulter de cracher sur
les policiers impunément parce que
l'infraction d'outrage va être relevée
par celui qui en est victime est-ce
qu'on donc on doit comme certains le
demandent dépénaliser ça c'est à dire
qu'il sera gratuit maintenant
encore une fois d'insulter les policiers
alors pour diminuer les plaintes pour
outrage à Vannes comme dans toutes les
écoles de police de France la formation
des nouveaux policiers a été entièrement
revu depuis deux ans
merci à vous à disposition de l'exercice
de mise en situation
vont jouer aujourd'hui aux usagers
excédés dans un commissariat
maquillage compris
et de toute façon si on vous donne pas
un temps précis et qu'on vous demande
d'attendre au bout de 10 minutes vous
partez vous avez posé Eric et
psychologue c'est lui qui écrit les
scénarios sans cesse
de police tu passes dans le tutoiement
ou en fait tu te rends bien compte que
il ne répond pas à ta demande et puis à
ce moment-là ben voilà quoi tu commences
à mettre un peu la pression dans la
police on appelle ça un cours de
discernement ambiance police réalité
derrière la vitre le public derrière le
comptoir du commissariat deux élèves qui
ne connaissent rien du scénario préparé
par les instructeurs
[Musique]
une succession de citoyens excédés
cette semaine devant chez moi après vous
avez organisé parce que le stationnement
que vous aviez il est pas réglementaire
mais vous rigolez c'est devant chez moi
il faut mettre la plaque voiture sur
votre garage pour faire comprendre que
c'est votre voiture que c'est votre
garage si vous avez 10 ans que j'habite
là et peut-être que c'est peut-être un
nouvel agent quelque chose contre moi
c'est pas vous qui les payez les amandes
vous pensez que je suis une vache à lait
que je vous engraisser comme ça personne
n'a dit que vous étiez une vache à
l'aise trois fois droit quand même hein
en écrivant courrier ministère public en
expliquant votre situation écris moi ça
m'intéresse pas je vais écrire ça va
prendre trois semaines d'accord vous
savez ce que je vais faire et ben j'aime
stationner comme tous les jours depuis
10 ans devant chez moi d'accord je vais
attendre que votre collègue m'a quand
même pas le courage de mettre son nom il
vient de me [__] un petit papillon
comme ça et puis vous savez ce que je
vais faire et ben je vais en découdre
avec lui puisque c'est comme ça Ciao
on va demander aux plastron de revenir
on va débriefer à chaud premier réflexe
des élèves relevez l'outrage
pour vous vous faites de déchirer le
timbre amende qu'un collègue a pu lui
déposer rogner l'infraction et nous le
lance nous le lancer
et quelle réponse vous auriez pu donner
à ce monsieur qui déchire
le procès-verbal quels sont les suites
de son axe
et
c'est ce que je voulais lui dire j'ai
pas eu le temps et vous avez couru après
pour lui dire ça
menottes outrage leur réaction est jugée
excessive on voit que la seule réponse
qu'ils ont à fournir c'est l'officier du
ministère public ou l'impossibilité de
toute façon de voir cette personne mais
il lui demande pas derrière et ils
auraient pu demander mais pourquoi ils
veulent le voir
alors s'expliquer mais s'expliquer
pourquoi qu'est-ce que l'usager veut
très précisément
mais qu'il allait s'expliquer ça veut
dire quoi là il faut aller jusqu'au bout
de la démarche et ce l'entendre dire
mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez
exactement pour vous expliquer avec lui
ça veut dire quoi mais pourquoi faire
pour que lui-même prenne conscience de
l'aberration de ce qu'il demande à un
moment il va quand même bien réussir à
comprendre que vous ne pouvez laisser un
contact entre un usager et un policier à
des fins de pouvoir en découdre
les trois stagiaires sont sur leur garde
en attendant le déclenchement du
prochain scénario
dans le ventre il est parti vers où
l'individu là à l'instant
l'individu c'est lui un copain de
promotion qui prend son rôle très à cœur
objectif du test vérifiez que les élèves
se concentrent bien sur le délit le plus
grave sans s'arrêter aux violences
verbales
on va faire un contrôle d'identité
[Musique]
les stagiaires récupèrent portefeuille
et sac à dos de la victime le faux caïd
résiste il passe à la consigne suivante
interpellation menottes dans la réalité
c'est souvent à ce moment-là que les
insultes fusent le policier lui ne doit
jamais oublier ses bonnes manières
fils de [__]
là
j'improvisation doit être crédible
jusqu'au bout
de débriefing
ça va être le vol où il y a aussi
l'outrage et la rébellion
ce sera le vol et la rébellion
actuellement sur on peut cumuler sur les
procédures on peut mettre plusieurs
infractions
en général on le prend pas pour nous moi
personnellement je crois que je crois
pas pour moi les collèges je pense pas
non plus là on fait notre métier on est
dans une situation on essaie de
travailler dans notre bonne position
après l'individu mais s'il veut parler
il parle mais là honnêtement ce qu'ils
disent nous intéresse pas nous intéresse
pas donc il nous apprennent à faire
abstraction de tout ce qu'on entend
enfin le plus possible moi je voudrais
vous féliciter pour pour l'intervention
parce que
elle est bien menée vous avez fait
preuve d'une parfaite maîtrise dans
l'interpellation
pour votre faculté absorbée toute cette
dose d'agressivité dégagée par l'auteur
présumé des faits
le policier n'est pas en dehors de la
société je dis souvent aux élèves moi je
suis père de famille comme d'autres
collègues formateurs et j'ai quand même
conscience que le métier de policier
c'est un métier qui est difficile mais
mes enfants quand ils circulent dans la
rue j'ai envie moi aussi que mes enfants
soient confrontés à des policiers bien
formés
des policiers mieux formés dans les
écoles pour eux maintenant reste à
confronter ces principes de discernement
et de retenue avec la réalité du terrain
en formation
[Musique]
pour un policier porter plainte pour
outrage et rébellion ne coûte rien après
examen par les juristes de la police la
plainte et transmise à un avocat en
contrat annuel avec l'administration
au revoir à Lyon mettre Versini est l'un
d'eux
le ministère de l'Intérieur le rémunère
au forfait de 300 à 700 euros par
plainte en fonction de la gravité des
faits un policier peut en principe aller
jusqu'en cours de cassation sans jamais
rien débourser
c'est le ministère de la terreur qui
réglera la facture de nos horaires que
je présenterai bien évidemment il paye
tout le policier à aucun moment même si
il est reconnu hier relax et même s'il
n'y a pas de
policier ne verse rien il y a
effectivement la loi de 1983 si ma
mémoire est bonne qui permet
effectivement aux fonctions de police de
bénéficier d'un système de protection
juridique le total est complet avec
Maître vercini les policiers lyonnais
savent qu'ils sont défendus par un
convaincus le choix de défendre la
police et la gendarmerie est un choix
savamment mûri qui bien évidemment et
c'est là aussi une sorte de
discrimination qui est faite à l'endroit
et des policiers et de ceux qui les
défendent c'est à dire que dès lors
qu'on s'oriente dans ce entre guillemets
contentieux de la police nationale et de
leurs gendarmerie et bien on est un
petit peu considéré comme les pestiférés
ah oui oui on est un petit peu considéré
comme les pestiférés des pestiférés
selon maître Versini qui pourtant gagne
presque à tous les coups en tout cas
j'aurais eu plaisir à t'avoir mon frère
confrère maître saint qui l'affrontent
régulièrement à la barre en sait quelque
chose
non mais mon confrère sain ta confrère
avec lequel on entretient d'excellentes
relations et c'est très bien mais on est
souvent de chacun de l'autre côté de la
barre qui gagne d'habitude
malheureusement dans ce procédure
d'outrage et de rébellion ou de violence
policières pour certaines si vous me
permettez de les qualifier cette fois-ci
c'est bien trop souvent la police qui a
le dernier mot mais c'est eux qui font
les procédures au terme desquelles les
décisions sont rendues
un très net avantage procédure on
sentait on sent déjà la plaie de Harry
de mon confrère ça qui se prépare contre
moi dans un dossier de la semaine
prochaine peut-être et dans ton dos oui
on y est à chaque fois l'avocat demande
des dommages et intérêts 200 à 500 euros
qui vont directement dans la poche des
policiers il y aurait-il un risque
d'incitation à la plainte pour outrage
si la majorité des policiers ne porte
jamais plainte d'autres les multiplient
ce matin maître vercing reçoit bâtisse
un brigadier qu'il connaît bien
alors merci d'être venu à nouveau en
novembre carrière il a déjà porté
plainte une trentaine de fois
l'affaire d'aujourd'hui est une plainte
pour rébellion une jeune femme qui
contestait les conditions d'une
intervention elle est devenue
complètement hystérique
elle a à me tait beaucoup de gens qui
trouvaient en plein centre-ville et
commencer à avoir une petite mais un
rassemblement de personnes qui
écoutent la dame était hostile à ce
contrôle vous avez souvent été confronté
à ce genre de d'attitude de personnes
extérieures qui viennent s'immiscer
c'est aujourd'hui très fréquent ça m'est
encore arrivé pas plus tard que samedi
ah bon sur un contrôle
alors que nous prenons contrôle d'un
homme toujours pareil des personnes qui
n'ont rien à voir avec ce contrôle
interviennent alors aussi bien le
président l'affaire du jour l'avocat
contre réclamé à la jeune femme 1800
euros de dommages et intérêts pour les
trois policiers un salaire ennemi ce ne
sont pas disproportionnés non ce n'est
pas du racket lorsqu'on ouvre la bouche
pour dire des choses on le dit en toute
connaissance de cause donc raison garder
il faut savoir aussi en apprécier les
conséquences pécuniaires les
conséquences pénales les conséquences
pécuniaires j'attends pas cet argent
j'en ai pas besoin
un portefeuille est touché je pense
qu'elle prend la conscience de ça elle
c'est cette jeune femme à vélo cela fait
4 ans que le policier son avocat la
poursuivi en justice pour rebellion en
plein centre-ville ce jour-là et
l'assiste au contrôle d'identité de deux
jeunes à scooters un contrôle qu'elle
trouve trop musclé j'ai dit bravo le
policier qui était donc de mon côté m'a
demandé si j'avais un problème je leur
ai répondu que non et que j'étais dans
un espace public je pense avoir le droit
de m'y exprimer ils m'ont demandé mes
papiers j'ai expliqué que je les avais
pas j'ai pris mon vélo je suis parti
sans dépêcher plus que ça ils m'ont
coupé la route avec leur voiture
policia a fait ami maman derrière le dos
il m'a projeté sur le sol un jurlais je
pleurais les gens disaient mais lâcher
là elle a rien fait
dans leur plainte les policiers parlent
d'incitation à l'émeutes mais en
première instance 4 personnes viennent
témoigner en faveur de la jeune femme et
elle est relaxer
les policiers et leur avocat refusent le
verdict ils font appel l'audience
s'ouvre aujourd'hui
4 ans plus tard chacun reste dans son
coin
[Musique]
j'ai rien contre elle il y a 4 ans
peut-être qu'elle a voulu depuis
peut-être pas on a des opinions
différentes enfin pour ça qu'on doit se
taper dessus voilà maintenant quand on a
une uniforme on le respecte moi
j'imagine pas faire
agir comme ça vous allez policier quand
on connaît pas le début de l'affaire on
se tait moi quand il y a un sujet que je
maîtrise pas je me bats je mets pas
dedans
la jeune femme elle est encore sous le
choc
mettre deux bras la défend depuis le
début de la fête
branche alors vous étiez un peu besoin
qu'est-ce que vous avez compris de
l'initiative des policiers dans tout ça
c'est que la prochaine fois faudrait que
je me taise voilà donc c'est tout ce que
j'en retiens et c'est
c'est oui ce que j'ai retenu en quelque
sorte
faut que je me taise
rien de plus à dire que ça c'est pas le
respect de l'uniforme que vous avez
appris là
le respect de l'uniforme
le respect d'uniforme c'est plutôt la
peur de l'uniforme que le respect de
l'uniforme
la cour la jeune femme étendue cette
fois c'est 4 témoins ne sont pas venus
exceptionnellement le Président nous a
autorisé à filmer une partie de
l'audience
peut-être sur le sol donc j'ai pas si on
peut appeler ça une rebellion mais si
elle allait nous avait suivi ça n'aurait
pas dérapé bonjour mademoiselle contrôle
d'identité présentez-nous une pièce
d'identité au revoir madame c'était
réglé on peut pas non plus toujours se
rabaisser pour que ça se passe bien je
sollicite de la cour sur le plan
indemnitaire et sur l'action civile
d'octroyer de l'éductible dommage
intérêts au profit des fonctionnaires de
la police nationale là on est dans la
disproportion absolue 600 euros pour peu
juste Morel qui est plus que la moitié
d'un SMIC moi je veux bien mais en
termes d'exemplarité aussi de des
demandes qui sont faites je veux dire
c'est choquant
il y a l'audience élevée un mois plus
tard la jeune femme est condamnée à 900
euros d'amende plus 400 euros à chacun
des trois policiers en ajoutant tous les
frais d'avocat cette affaire lui coûte
près de 6000 euros avec inscription au
casier judiciaire
6000 euros pour avoir commenté un
contrôle d'identité c'est à ce prix-là
que ce jour-là la justice a fixé le
respect de l'uniforme
[Musique]